to answer your questions I've asked you
two questions should a mass stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that on TV on radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on PE organiz Sor first the
bet now the backlash prime minister
rishy sunak wager with me on the Rwanda
plan Sparks a frenzy of headlines and an
impassion debate was he gambling with
vulnerable people's lives or putting his
money where his mouth
is Prince Harry lands in Britain after
bombshell news his father the King has
cancer the Duke of Sussex were told will
not be meeting his brother Prince
William is Harry's visit an unwanted
distraction and teacher Warren Smith
goes viral for calmly and critically
educating a student on the difference
between being offended and what is
actually offensive more than 40 million
have watched that video who give me his
first
interview live from the news building in
London this is Pierce Morgan uncensored
good evening from l welcome to Piers
Morgan on senson it's the bet that
rocked Britain two guys making a wager
doesn't often become a global news event
but my challenge to the Prime Minister
on his plan to send Asylum Seekers to
Rwanda triggered an enormous reaction
and appears to have triggered an
enormous number of people here's a
reminder of what actually happened I'll
bet you ,000 to a refugee charity you
don't get anybody on those planes before
the election will you take that back
well I well I want to get the people on
the planes right of course I want to get
the people on the
right I want to get the people on the
plane and and you say you scratching
your head Albania is an example of why
it's working we created a new returns
agreement with Albania it meant that if
people came here illegally we could send
them back and you know what they stopped
coming R and Rwanda will do the same
thing for us do not think it's going to
work for you okay well we'll have to
agree to disagree that's my Grim
prediction but you don't have an
alternative way to solve that problem
then uh no I'm not prime
minister yet and here's just a small
sample of the Fallout which has vied
with news of the king's health for
headline coverage and even made it to
the houses of
Parliament how frustrating for you that
yesterday our prime minister said that
he was willing to risk
,000 on the basis of a bet and it was a
charity bet wasn't it I didn't have a
problem with it at all to be honest with
you I think two multi-millionaires
having a bet amongst themselves it was
absolutely appalling I've never heard
such garbage um come out from an a
politician in my life was it deeply
distasteful as labor have called it or
would he have been criticized for not
backing the BET as one conservative
commentator has argued can you confirm
for the house Mr Deputy speaker that a
1,000 direct pecuniary personal interest
is one which should be registered and
declared to the house
authorities well richy sux political
Rivals are feasting on the moment as
You' expect the lib dens called it
shameful the S SMP said it's grotesque
and rather hysterically I thought
reported the Prime Minister for
breaching the ministerial code as they
put it Labour says it proves he's out of
touch they also posted this ad saying
while your pockets are bare ry's betting
with a grand he has to spare not the
greatest poetry I think I've read in a
while but first things first they didn't
actually use the right handshake there
Labour party they want to think about
that that's him thanking me at the end
of the interview not accepting the BET
and where I come from Mr Prime Minister
you might try and wle off the hook but a
handshake a seal bet uh secondly it's
worth noting the Richi sunak has now
braved two extended uncensored
interviews with me while he's being
prime minister Sakia starma who wants to
be prime minister has repeatedly told me
to my face you'll come on the show and
has pre appeared precisely zero times so
when a lot of the labor MPS hit social
media today led by Jess Phillips saying
my God he can't even cope with Pierce
Morgan what hope has he got with
Vladimir Putin well your leader doesn't
appear to be a to cope with me at all
former labor spin do aliser Campbell you
may remember him he spun us into an
illegal war that cost the deaths of over
a million people posted most of the
audience at my book event tonight were
unaware of the sunac Rwanda bet when I
described The Exchange there were
literally sharp intakes of breath and
reactions of disgust in the audience if
it crossed alistair's mind that that
might have been the moment they
remembered what he did when he was in
Downing Street with Tony
Blair so a lot of reaction um and I
don't know how I feel about this other
than to say that when I see Carol vman
an old friend of mine used to work with
me at the Daily Mirror tweeting
hysterically resign rishy Zak about the
bet you're an utter disgrace to his
country and forgotten sitcom actor
Robert Lindsay he was good don't get me
wrong loved him as Wolfie Smith Ed did
dear anyone with an ounce of humanity a
PM and a TV presenter having a bet on
Desperate people's lives and so on and
so on and so on I do think a lot of
people may have lost the plot in the
Maelstrom of pearl clutching in the last
24 hours and forgotten actually that I
did start the process of this wager by
saying the BET proceeds would go to a
refugee charity I was actually trying to
flush out the prime minister's
conviction and a policy that I believe
has always been doomed to failure and is
bad for this country he was trying to
underscore his genuine belief that it
could work and I guess you could say he
was putting his money where his mouth is
and we all know he has plenty of money
to do that with but like I say no one
ends up with any money here other than a
refugee charity and what is almost
certainly going to happen I suspect is
that I will win this bet nobody will end
up being sent to Rwanda on a plane and a
refugee charity will be £1,000 better
off could argue that's quite a good
win-win all around well the Prime
Minister himself was asked to clarify
the wager this morning I'm being totally
honest I'm not a betting person and I
was taken totally by surprise in the
middle of uh that interview and the
point I was trying to get was it a
mistake to shake his hand no well the
point I was trying to get across I said
I was taken totally by surprise was it a
mistake to take my hand well I'm not
Hannibal Lector um the best questions
are always a surprise even for prime
ministers it should be noted he has not
officially withdrawn the bet I wouldn't
let him handshakes a handshake uh former
Tory leader William hay though had some
interesting tips on how he would have
handled this he said he'd have attacked
me with his martial arts what do you do
there William how do you do do you shake
his hand do you make the BET do you
think that's all right or do you do
avoid that
landmine it' be really nice to do a judo
move on it holding out his hand
um however that's the sort of thing I
can fantasize about today and couldn't
have done when I was a party leader uh
so
to bat the hand
away fantasizing about grappling me in a
judo Hal this a man who wanted to be
prime minister should be known as the
same William hag who once boasted of
drinking 14 pints a day obviously a
tough cookie uh and Sam coats over at
Sky News gave this analysis you know the
point about that exchange with Pierce
Morgan um and and and actually you know
listening to Rich try not very well to
defend it this morning he's like he just
gets dragged into stuff you know but
youve got to deal with more difficult
people than PEB you got to deal with
Vladimir Putin who says that Putin is
more difficult to me what' you base that
on shame on you Sam coat I was going to
mention James obbr over at LBC who was
ranting way about me but he does it so
often and he's so insufferably
irritating I'm going to spare you my own
viewers from having to even see his face
now at the heart of all this is a
serious issue I said repeatedly I don't
believe the Roman plan is either
practical or affordable or indeed Humane
I think the PM is finally making some
progress on illegal immigration with the
boats he's got them down substantially
thanks to a deal with Albania but this
Rwanda plan as I said to him to his face
is a cack-handed plan that is just never
going to work and the BET prime minister
most definitely stands when Jord have
discussed this is talk to the
contributor and lawyer Paul lone Adrian
the author and journalist Paul Mason and
talk TV International editor Isabelle
oakshaw okay right well I've got Paul
and Paula and I know where you're both
going to come at me from uh Paul look I
I I was surprised it blew up this big if
I'm honest with you because really the
point I was making was it's for charity
of this bet but are you going to put
your money where your mouth is and I can
see the way it's it's played out
obviously very differently to how it
felt in the room at the time what was
your view of this well I'm like you I'm
against the Rwanda plan I don't think
it'll work I think it's unfair I think
it's probably illegal in international
law and it costs a lot of money but if I
was in favor of it I would try and
present it to the public a in a little
bit more sober way I thought it
trivialized it because it it may be that
British doesn't know this but there were
some migrants put on a plane in June
2022 refugees to go to Rwanda stopped by
the courts they were dragged onto that
plane and chained to the floor and I I
accept that deportations have to happen
in a fair IM migration system some
people have to be deported but when we
do that on our all our behalfs we've got
to maintain the idea to the rest of the
world that we're Humane and we care
about those people even if they fail to
were you J you said you you found it
morally or whatever you said I said it
was morally vacuous right and a lot of
people said similar sentiments I think
there's a ugv poll said 72% of Britain
think it was unacceptable for sunak to
accept my bet but I haven't seen much
reference to the fact that are going to
a refugee charity let people may have
missed that it was a news making
interview let's accept that the the
point is First It's a grand you know I
was in my local Tesco just now and and
watching you know young moms looking at
whether or not they can afford what's on
the shelves a grand to such people
sounds like a lot even in North Allon
and Richmond you know I'm not sure how
many Rich's constituents would have
found that very tasteful but then they
all know they all know he's stinking
rich I called him stiny rich last time I
interviewed him but the issue then is
let's not trivialize the fate of a lot
of people a lot of Tory MPS not just Mr
sunak often say we can't wait to to to
see the planes take off when I hear them
say that I think what about the people
in the planes they've you know as a
journalist I've been to Morocco
interviewed people on wastelands people
from njer and said to them look when you
get here you're going to risk dying to
get here there'll be a lot of racism
when you get here and you'll be poor why
are you doing it and they say come to
ner and and you'll find out I.E the idea
that the deterrent effect is going to
stop them coming well I don't think
it'll be a deterrent effect I mean Paul
I'll bring you in here I just don't
think it it's I don't think it works on
any level they've already admitted the
government pretty much that even if they
do get it through Parliament get these
people onto planes we're only talking
about a couple of hundred people a vast
expense maybe three 400 million pounds
to the British tax pay it makes no
commercial economic sense whatsoever but
my biggest problem with it is I think we
should be a country which can deal with
illegal immigration properly with a
proper policy and the far bigger problem
at the moment of a soaring legal
immigration issue which is exploding our
entire population um but also we should
be a country which can take Asylum
Seekers who Warren coming in as Asylum
Seekers and if we send people to Rwanda
and even if they fulfill the criteria
for entries or something we don't let
them come back what Have We Become as a
country absolutely and and I think I
just want to be able to answer your
question in terms of you being surprised
at the reaction to this bear I'm
disappointed that you're surprised um
I'm not surprised it was crass it was
crude um you were playing with people's
lives no I was that's ridiculous that's
a ridiculous thing to say people have
died I
was to this I'm actually trying to stop
those people being played with but you
but you
played what I was doing a crude I was
doing
two wealthy men what's the weal to do
suggested that oh let's just you know
put our put our hands in our back
pockets and pull out ,000 to a refugee
charity finish the sentence but we lost
the refugee charity you should use it
let me let me why we lost the refugee
Char your it seems to be your solution
is refug Char shouldn't get ,000 no
because rishy has already spent
240 million of the British taxpayers
money taay money on this failed event
well he didn't say to be fair in the
interview where the, was coming from to
me did you watch the interview and and I
you see the whole debate about Rwanda I
didn't I so the idea that I'm playing
with people's lives when I was actively
trying to stop the British prime
minister from going through with a
policy which I think is playing with
people's lives I find that offensive
well tell what's what's happened is pi
is that you're a slick interrogator and
what you did I'm a journalist and what
you did was you led I used I used the
onto that and he was like it was
reminiscent of Bambi on ice skates was
it it was just a car crash and how he
can really contain himself today is to
me he must be cringing so yes it was a
joke maybe not to you but clearly to I
did what people do to many of his
constituents up and down the country all
the time right they have an argument
they reach a place where they're not
agreeing they go I'll bet you you can't
get this to work right I didn't mean it
as any ins to people I was trying to
stop people being in my view it
mistreated by this country right now the
surprise to me was only that the Prime
Minister accepted the bet now that may
have been a misjudgment on his part he
was probably calculating in the moment
you know what if I don't it looks like I
don't believe in my policy if damned if
I do damned if I don't and maybe that
was a sharp Moment by me to flush that
out that hesitation by him but I do
think I mean Paul I do think some of the
reaction has has been ridiculous well I
haven't seen all the reaction but what I
would say is I don't share your
criticism of of you you know as a
journalist when one makes a news makak
interview you know you want to make the
headlines yeah um you spent a long time
with him I watched the whole interview a
long time and what was clear to me was
that the Prime Minister was in many ways
accepting your premises at every point
in the argument and that as a human
being let alone journalist when you find
someone doing that you you do start to
wonder should this guy be running the
country
and let's see how far he'll go I've done
that in interviews with people where I
felt that that really they're out of
their depth no I don't want to be unfair
to prime minister because any live
interview with a senior journalist is a
tough thing but in the end I just think
he's out of touch and and the out of
touch I have no problem with you
offering uh to to bet a grand for a
refugee charity but what what I do have
is the idea that he th thrown that sort
of sort of funny enough to sort of think
oh I can do this well I think he I think
he flaming him actually I mean let be be
fair I think he flamed him in the moment
he didn't really know what to do and
people criticize and say what he should
do he's only been Prime he should have
exerted his author of course every prime
minister will tell you and I'm sure
you've had conversations with him that
they are at their best the day after
they lose their jobs right they get
fully trained properly experienced and
then they get fired let me bring in
Isabelle oot has been listening
patiently to this Isabelle um a lot of
Hysteria about what I thought was a
fairly Sharp piece of journalistic
stunter to elicit a genuinely
fascinating response which it
did well what a load of sanctimonious
twaddle from both Paul and Paula I mean
Paula hasn't even uh watched the whole
interview so it's rather difficult to
imagine how she can possibly be
pronouncing on it B said she was
disappointed and I too am disappointed
Piers because I think you could have bet
a whole lot more on that policy not
working have you fallen on hard times or
something I mean I honestly I just came
up with a figure in the moment I had no
idea what I was really going to come up
with I just thought it'd be interesting
interesting to test his result
interesting to see what he I just
thought a lot more well probably L I
don't think yeah I mean both of you
could have afforded a lot more and at
the end of the day which whatever the
outcome of the BET whether you're right
and the policy doesn't work which I
happen to completely agree with you I
think it's a very safe bet or he's right
and he manages to get this policy off
the ground Refugee charity is ,000 PS
better off so I'm really struggling to
see how anyone can genuinely criticize
that it's the first time I've ever heard
either a successful TV presenter or a
prime minister being criticized for
being too generous in donating money to
charity well I exactly what I thought I
thought honestly and they all
deliberately left that bit out of of it
they're all ranting away about rich
people spending all nobody mentioned in
their critiques that this was actually a
bet for charity that's how I preface the
whole thing um what was interesting I
think about the interview Isabel I know
you've seen it all now was there were
other things in that interview that I
felt were much more newsworthy one was
where he basically called K starma a
terror sympathizer uh over this band
group we had that NHS doctor on the show
who's who leads the UK arm of that now
prescribed terror group in this country
and he basically called starma a terror
sympathizer for trying to stop them
becoming a prescribed Group by acting
for them and the other thing I thought
was uh really newsworthy uh was the the
confirmation by the Prime Minister that
one of his key five pledges to get NHS
waiting list down which he actually
coupled with sorting out the crisis in
the A&E uh he failed on let's take a
look NHS waiting list we have not made
enough prog you failed on that pledge
cuz you said any waiting this will fall
but the waiting is still nearly half a
million more than it was at the start of
last year so My mother is 79 and she had
a heart attack three months ago and she
was taken to her local hospital and she
was seen when she got there and then she
was put on a trolley in A&E in a
corridor for nearly 7
hours the heart monitor battery ran out
nobody fixed it at one stage no nurse
came for three or four hours and she was
also terrified of course having been
told you've had a heart attack that no
one was putting her into the unit and
actually trying to fix her now once she
got up there the treatment she got was
world class but I you know I brought
this one picture to show you that's you
that's my mom and when she really needed
the NHS yeah eventually the NHS came
through but she could have died on that
trolley and I think that's shocking
yeah that is a shocking story and I'm
really glad that she's feeling better
now and send her my best and I'm glad
she got the treatment that she needed
this was a Monday night prime minister
this wasn't even the weekend yeah it's
not even a major city this is Brighton
and there were 40 yard people on
trolleys in a
corridor well you know I got an email
today which we we're trying to uh
corroborate Isabelle but it was from
somebody else exactly at the same
Hospital whose mother died on a troll in
thate and was there 24 hours well and I
I think this is going on up and down I
want to pick up on that yeah I really
want to pick up on that because if I
were the labor party or any opposition
party I would play that particular clip
of your interview on a loop and look at
the prime minister's reaction to me this
is the most insightful bit of the
interview there is something very very
wrong about the prime minister's
reaction to your story he just has he
shows no empathy there is no form of
shock in his reaction to your story he's
robotic about it and that really really
jars with me and you know I am so glad
to hear that when your mom was finally
taken up onto the ward that she got the
treatment that you described you said it
was world class um but you in a sense
you were lucky look my mother recently
died in an NHS Hospital I am sorry to
say that she died in front of a lot of
people that none of us had any privacy
and in the seconds after she died my
sisters and I were taken into a store
cupboard because there was nowhere
private for us to go so I wasn't
planning on sharing that story but the
prime minister's reaction to your story
has if you like triggered me to do that
because it was so lacking in any real
empathy for the many many thousands of
people tonight who are on Hospital
trolleys and are not getting the
treatment that they deserve the NHS is
failing and he's admitted it and it's
failed on his
watch yeah well I'm very sorry about
your mom you and I have talked about
that before and Incredibly sad for you
and I feel very fortunate that my mother
was able to come through it you know she
have a heart attack in your late 70s and
then spend seven hours on a trolley
thinking what is happening to me with
the heart monitor regularly running out
of batteries and no one seemed to notice
him was scary a um Paul what you what
did you make of that part of the
interview again I was looking at his
face and thinking look prime minister
doesn't get to meet a lot of ordinary
people and when he does you know you
were very measured with him but imagine
we can all imagine a voter saying the
same story what would happen in general
is that the people behind him would just
gently Edge him away and I think that
what if he can learn anything it is
listen to these ordinary sto stories I
bet every single one of us including all
your studio uh staff could tell the same
story I've got stories of 48 hours in a
I've had so many in the last few days
but it's but so the NHS is failing it so
happens that we've had one party in
government for 14 years but I'd say you
know there is a long-term problem NHS I
actually think my hunch I don't know
about you and Isabelle my hunch is that
people care a lot more about these
stories of everyday hardship uh than
they do about whether the Rwanda scheme
deports 200 and actually care Paula more
about the reality of human stories than
do about the over toop line statistics
you can hear 7.6 million people on
waiting list you can hear A&E's out of
control when you actually have a loved
one trapped in that nightmare of waiting
for a lot to save their life or waiting
to get into through a& it is terrifying
absolutely and I think there's two
things here the first is that you're
right you know when he when he's
approached by a member of the public we
saw it just a couple of weeks ago um he
laughed in
response he was C of C he didn't know
what to do but well that CL was cut
unfairly actually they then show
that happens now the second point I
wanted to make though was about the
disconnect it's the disconnect that we
recognize in this story about your
mother and it's the same disconnect that
we recognize in terms of the bed we're
talking about um our prime minister who
doesn't have the capacity to be
sensitive enough to understand that when
he's asked about making a bet on what is
something that for many is a life or
death situation be it about the NHS be
it about Rwanda that he can just limply
shake your hand um on a policy that we
know or we are being told aren't we that
he doesn't even agree with but he's
having to push through look I like isab
I wasn't going to say this but I think I
will just to be balanced about it
because the idea that he doesn't care
for example about my mother and what
happened to her and whatever facial
reaction he showed at the time I can
tell you he sent her a big bunch of
flowers yesterday and then he followed
up and called her without any recourse
to me whatsoever uh called her for 10
minutes minutes and had a really lovely
chat with her the problem is there
you're
you but it was nice thing to you know if
only had sent my mom a bunch of course
he can't s he can't everybody but my
point being that I don't think he's a
nures and I don't think he didn't care I
don't think he's Harless I think he does
care but I think that you know I give
them a little bit of slack politicians
for facial expressions when they're
being jumped with stuff which they're
not really sure what it's all about and
I can just say that my mother was very
touched by both the flowers and the
phone call and greatly appreciated what
he said to her and she certainly came
away thinking this guy does care now I
completely accept I'm a television
presenter and it was a big interview
everyone's talking about it and not
everyone gets that Prime ministerial
treatment but he did do that and I've
not had a prime minister do that to any
of my family before we're not voting uh
for the conservative party on the basis
of whether rishy has sent your mom
flowers of course that's not
listen we run out of time I'm simply
trying to balance up the he doesn't care
narrative which I don't think is fair he
He does care I saw it I spoke to him
afterwards uh for quite a while actually
after the interview he definitely cares
right um but we'll have to see whether
doing about that well that the question
is can any can any leader right now fix
NHS is a much bigger question I'm not
sure well maybe maybe and he'll get he
may get a chance for the end of the year
to prove it we got we got to leave it
there guys I'm sorry we're run out of
time thank you uh Paul and Isabelle
thank you all very much indeed I
appreciate it on S next Prince Harry
returns to the UK to visit his father
the king but he has no plans to meet his
brother Prince William what does that
mean think we know what it means William
would rather shoot himself back after
the
break hey very good morning to you
thanks for joining us you're with talk
TV on TV on radio online and we on your
smart speaking good morning Rosie good
morning Nick we're here in torth for you
to find out exactly why some people are
traveling halfway around the world and
queuing for hours for one of these The
Humble British
potato a woman can become a man and a
man can become a woman and if you think
that you're certifiably
insane it's not in Labor's DNA to get
tough on immigration they don't feel it
they don't sense
it this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of a street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense she was basically saying that
if I don't leave then she's going to
seize my equipment and everyone around
was just
outraged a crossbow a hatchet multiple
crossbows multiple crossbow yeah
crossbows is what it says on the Press
crossbows and a carry on a crossbows and
Hatchet and what a sword and a knife how
is that even technically
possible where we going
it's carry on what just
happened was like brought to you by St
KH the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got a great mayor
sad Khan brilliant
guy nobody is is spending any money
they're not prepared to do it I mean why
is that H quite simple the downturn in
the spend is three simple words
Financial fair
play stop creating all of these funny
little actions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that absolutely right if I want
to have a Hubba Bubba chalky walkie
Bazooka Joe flavored Vape I can have one
but not according to rishy sunak because
he said no we can't trust you with that
Donald Trump didn't just win he
obliterated this is a guy facing nearly
a hundred criminal charges and yet all
that's done is actually make him more
popular Trump is canny enough to know
that all publicity is good publicity I
don't want a president who's been
impeached if he's able to bamboozle you
that's the way it goes I did my six
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted and
carried on when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should have has
stay in power and are they terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that
welcome back to sensor King Charles and
queen Killa were seen publicly for the
first time since the news of the king's
cancer diagnosis yesterday at Prince
Harry the Duke of SX flen overnight from
Los Angeles father and son had a brief
meeting at Clarence house this morning
about 45 minutes uh from all accounts
however any hope this could be the
beginning of a royal Repro more seemed
dashed this afternoon Harry apparently
had but told has no plans to meet up
with his brother Prince William so that
Feud continues unabated uh is Harry's
visit and unwanted distraction at a time
of crisis or was he damned if he came
and damned if he didn't my Pat the Royal
historian author Tessa Dunlop the role
biographer and expert Tom bow author of
Charles II new king new court Robert
Harbour number one bestselling book
congratulations um but first I thought
of the Sunday Times is Roy Royer Nic
Royer
um big developments it seemed to me
today well obviously Harry flying in
meeting up with his father at Clarence
house but only for about 40 minutes
maximum before the king went by
helicopter with the queen up to sandran
and then this briefing that there was
going to be no meeting planned between
him and William so I my first question
really do we know any more yet about
what this cancer is are we likely to
know what it is is sort of a mounting
speculation but is that going to lead to
any
Clarity I don't think P that's going to
lead to Clarity anytime soon I think
what they what the what the thinking on
that probably is is first of all privacy
for yes is H state in a very public
figure but also a man who's been
diagnosed with cancer but secondly I
think you know the king and and the
palace team and and the queen will want
to see how Charles's treatment go before
we think about going into any more um
detail about what cancer he actually has
in terms of you know that meeting today
I'm not sure we should read too much
into the length of time I mean know
Charles has had his treatment he wanted
to get back to Sandringham I think the
key thing is that Harry saw his father
for the first time really in person face
to face chatting since the queen funeral
because they didn't speak at the
coronation U we know that Harry came and
left he didn't go back to the Palace of
reception um and you know it's been very
strained and but you know barely
existing that relationship in terms of
face to face so I think it's a good
thing that um father and son have seen
each other but I mean William and Harry
absolutely no thoring of the ice
whatsoever I don't think that comes as
any surprise to anyone though does it I
don't think anyone really who knows
what's gone on there um and the status
quo thinks that Harry flying in to see
his father is going to open up some huge
reconciliation with his brother um and I
don't think Harry would have expected
that and I think of course you mentioned
the fact that it was briefed out that
William had no plans to see his brother
you know that's sending a very strong
message but I don't think that comes as
a huge
surprise I don't you know everyone's
sort of speculating about a thoring of a
rift but actually this is just a father
and a son seeing each other after a
cancer
diagnosis what is going to happen with
the Royal schedule for this year do we
know any more yet about the length of
time this treatment is likely to
take so again they've been quite
unspecific about that and queries that
we've made about you know well tour
overseas tours go ahead we know there
was supposed to be a tour to Canada and
further a field and the Autumn that huge
trip to Commonwealth heads of government
meeting in Sam and there was expected to
be a trip to Australia too all of that I
think will hang in the balance just so
that Charles until Charles knows how his
treatment goes and how he feels after
all of that so at the moment
the only thing that that buck Palace
will confirm is that the king continues
with all his state affairs right um
things like overseas visits and his
engagements we just don't know royya
thank you very much indeed for joining
us again I appreciate that we'll have a
short break and come back and debate all
this with our Superstar pack including
the number one bestselling author Robert
Harman how lucky are we to have him here
even Tom's looking at him going wow I'd
love a piece of that
action
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about to today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tories love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swearing off
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it it's hard
to know whether it's a fce or a tragedy
there needs to be one human per machine
to come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes Rong unexpected item in
bagging area no are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Gram was president of the Cambridge
unit which is the rubbish version of
being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational you talk
TV it's the only place where you get the
truth
[Music]
this is talk
TV welcome back to our s with me is the
Royal historian and author Tessa dun
Royal biographer and expert Tom bow and
the Royal expert and author of Charles
III new king new court Robert har we're
just comparing who's our more number
ones bestselling books I came in at
three uh obviously with his first one I
think yeah uh I've had one one more that
got to number one so two and then in
came B with six conratulations I
couldn't be less happy for
you all right let's let's talk Robert
you've written this amazing book it is a
it's a magnificent book about the new
king you could never have predicted when
you wrote this that within 17 months he
would be facing such a serious challenge
not just to his his Reign but to his
life no I mean he he always SE seemed uh
um someone who's very abstemious I mean
over all the years I I've been following
writing about him even made a program
with him once uh you know here's someone
who's very fit for his age lives a very
abstemious life doesn't drink much uh is
almost fastidious about health healthy
to the point doesn't even eat lunch
actually thinks lunch is bad for you um
and uh and and and is very fit and and
there can't be many people who SE have
celebrated a 70th birthday with both
parents still alive so you know do you
have any inkling from your many great
sources about what this cancer actually
is no I'm I'm I'm not privy to to to to
the sort of it must be serious for them
to be taking the action they're taking I
all cancer you know is serious I I I'm
what I what I am hearing is that he's
proving to be not a very good patient in
that he is still expecting to have all
the paperwork coming all the all the
stuff all the the non public interaction
stuff is continuing um when I was doing
the book I mean you know you talk to
people who who have or do work for him
and he does he keeps very late hours I
mean he is he is a hard worker he has
you know Tom will know Tom's written
about you know some of his padillos and
uh and and over the years he's had a had
an extraordinary life I mean a unique
life but the one thing that that that
runs through it is that whether at good
times or bad um he has this capacity to
he likes mountains of paper uh another
another thing that I think we've all
been so busy over the years um studying
his interest in other faiths you know
the long-standing thing about him
wanting to be a defender of faith that I
don't think we've paid much attention do
his own Fai and that actually is is much
deeper and stronger I discovered anyway
than I was aware of uh and and and I
think that's something that's going to
stand probably never more important than
it is right now absolutely Tessa let's
talk about uh the inevitable Harry's
flown in he had a 40 minute maximum
meeting with his father that might be it
we don't know maybe he flies back back
again um no sign of any reproach more
with his brother I mean what do you make
of this um I think that Harry's been
itching to build Bridges with his father
really from the the birthday call at the
back end of last year I think the omed
scobby book scuppered any Bridges being
built before Christmas and I think that
Harry as quick as he was out of the
traps is indicative of a son who wants
to find a way back in certainly with his
father against Tom he's never really had
the beef the beef was always
predominantly he did attack his father's
wife in his bookan it wasn't it wasn't
pretty and I'm sure pretty as ugly as it
gets I mean if one of my family left to
me they would be done I mean Tom we've
talked a lot about this but what do you
make of this this grandiose gesture I
mean on one level you could say well it
shows it must be a serious situation
because he didn't fly two weeks ago when
Charles had his benign prostate uh
procedure but he's flown straight in
here that does suggest to me it must be
serious but this Rift with William looks
pretty implacable if you can't come
together at a moment like this when can
you well I as I said last night to you I
was very suspicious about the dash and I
won't be surprised at all as I hinted
yesterday if he flies back tonight or
tomorrow I think it was all just for
show I think that it was an impromptu
way of getting attention I think he's a
very suspicious man he's wrote his book
for money he's been very disloyal and
I'd be very surprised if he met Camila
when he met the father when he met the
father and I think the only person he
might meet but now would be uh beatric
or Eugene but otherwise he'll go back
and I think that there's absolutely no
hint of reconciliation his wife is the
most bitter unreconciled woman there is
he'll be told that in any case there's
no future for him and I'm told that
Williams real rage is about what Harry
wrote about his he's right but he's
absolutely right what he wrote was ABS
grotesque only for money yeah and and
he's been terrible about his father as
well but I don't think we we should be
too suspicious about a son wanting to
have contact with his aging ill father I
think that is a a very simple familial
transaction whatever wat's gone under
the bridge I think it's all too easy to
cast dispersions and one hopes that
Charles is is larger dispersions are
cast because of the track record of
Harry and his wife in the last four five
he dashed up after the coronation he was
pretty but they haven't missed a chance
to sell sell trash about their family
and not only that he's he briefed omit
scobby for the second book which was a
disgraceful book we discussed it at the
time tell he wouldn't he he would have
got it in the neck if he hadn't come I
you said earlier you know damned if he
does damned if he doesn't I think um the
the the the jury stays out until we see
how uh you know this this trip is over
does he use it as an opportunity to
ground stand or is what does the king
really feel about this situation with
Harry and also about the situation
between his two sons with Harry it's
door is always open territory it's it's
he is forgiving he is not one to to Feud
on this I think you'd much rather uh
take a a bit of a hit and and and and
have a much more normal relationship
when it comes to the the brothers I
think he views it as look I that's for
William I can't sort of step in here
about cam Camila in all this because
she's had to step up now not just with
the duy she's performing may take on
some of the Kings but also this is the
love of her life who is facing this
enormous personal Health Challenge sure
but as you know p is a a broad
shouldered woman she's a mother herself
things get complicated we know that
Harry retreated into his bedroom he I'm
talk you actually about CH her her
feelings about what's going on with
Charles oh right well I think what's
interesting about Camila is the way in
which she's risen to the occasion she's
had these solo events she looks
impeccable you doesn't even look like
she's having this sort of personal storm
going on in her private life and I think
that this will reframe her in many ways
and and it will also I think help set
the tone for Harry's re-entry they all
those two they're mature adults Camila
and Charles they want well Tom one
thing's for sure they will know better
than anybody that you can be very
disliked by the British public and bring
things back they're both massively more
popular Charles and Camila than they
were in the aftermath of Diana's death
but you're assuming Harry wants to come
back I don't believe that for a moment
that may not be I don't think he wants I
don't think Megan wouldn't dream of
wanting to live in rainy London she
loves California and that's where their
life is and I think he just felt I mean
you know this is a man who a couple of
weeks ago went to Jamaica which he knew
is a sensitive spot just to stir up
publicity just to earn some more money
and cause a lot of trouble for Britain
there you know that couple are just
they're intent on causing trouble that
is their meal ticket Tom I don't think
that we should cast everything they do
through the prism of Great Britain I we
should judge should judge them on Miss
aspect and their actions have been
extremely damaging to the monarchy the
royal family and to his country so EXA
if they change their behavior I'm
prepared to change my view of them and
the criticism Robert just just finally
this is a big thing for the country to
deal with this again coming so soon
after the Queen's death Prince Phillip's
death you've got Kate who's just been in
hospital Fergie Duchess of York has had
two bats of cancer now it's it's a tough
time for people who like me and you love
the royal family and the monarchy it is
a tough time and it's it's it's you know
come at just as the Monch he had sort of
Consolidated itself I mean he had
enormous shoes to fill King Charles you
know I mean and and a lot of people
predicted it was going to be a uphill
challenge he would stray off into
politics he would blunder here and there
there' be a rise in republicanism that
hasn't been I think the monarchy is is
is in a very solid place I think he's
done a good job in less than a year and
a half of consolidating it and Along
Comes this but he's had plenty of other
shocks that Beyond his control I mean
when you think of uh you know not just
two rounds of The Crow
plus the Harry Megan's Netflix thing
plus always always Saga of of of Andrew
and and not to mention we haven't even
gotten to republicanism in the other
Realms and all that and yet we up until
last week we weren't really thinking
about the monarchy because it was doing
what it always does it was it had got
boring which is where it used to be
listen we've run we've run out of time
but if you want to know more about the
monarchy read this new king you Court
Charles II The Inside Story or the
Inside Man Robert har great to see you
congratulations great to see you too
thank you very much One sensor next more
than 40 million people watched a video
this weekend of teacher Warren Smith
delivering a masterclass in critical
thinking to a student he joins me after
the
[Music]
break hey very good morning to you
thanks for joining us you're with talk
TV on TV on radio online and we're on
your smart speaking good morning Rosie
good morning Nick we're here in Tamworth
for you to find out exactly why some
people are traveling halfway around the
world and queuing for hours for one of
these The Humble British
potato a woman can become a man and a
man can become a woman and if you think
that you're certifiably
insane it's not in Labor's DNA to get
tough on immigration they don't feel it
they don't sense
it this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly wing at the you know the
corner of the street or whatever I think
it's a
nonsense she was basically saying that
if I don't leave then she's going to
seize my equipment and everyone around
was just
outraged a crossbow a hatchet full
crossbows multiple crossbows yeah
crossbows is what it says on the Press
crossbows and a carry on a crossbows and
a hatchet and what a sword and a knife
how is that even technically
possible we going show it's carry on on
what just
happened was like brought to you by St
KH the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got a great mayor
sadique Khan brilliant
guy nobody is is spending any money
they're not prepared to do it I mean why
is that H quite simple the downturn in
the spend is three simple words
Financial fa
please stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservative the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that absolutely right if I want
to have a Hubba Bubba chalky walkie
Bazooka Joe flavored Vape I can have one
but not according to Rishi sunak because
he said no we can't trust you with that
Donald Trump didn't just win he
obliterated this is a guy facing nearly
a 100 criminal charges and yet all
that's done is make him more popular
Trump is canny enough to know that all
publicity is good publicity I don't want
a president who's been imp Peach if he's
able to bamboozle you that's the way it
com I did my 6 months I came back nobody
would touch me I put my head down and
persisted and C when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to S a school teacher
in Massachusetts the United States who
uses Harry Potter in his storytelling
course has gone viral of his response to
a student questioning about JK rling
supposed transphobia Warren Smith was
asked do you still like her work despite
her bigoted opinions what happened next
was a very Swift and forensic lesson in
critical thinking let's define bigoted
opinions what opinions are bigoted live
your best life do you find that transfer
I'm just going with what a lot of other
people have said at the beginning of
this conversation you said give the fact
that JK Rowling is transphobic how do
you feel about Harry Potter I feel like
an idiot
now off the video is shared by Elon Musk
has now been viewed over 40 million
times on musk's platform x with tens of
thousands of comments heaping Praise on
Warren for his master class and how to
think for yourself and Warren Smith
joins me now from Massachusetts uh
Warren well first of all congratulations
on having one of the biggest viral uh
things I've watched all year secondly
are you surprised
um because it's it's really captured I
think a mood of people desperate to see
teachers behaving this way where you
didn't take a position you simply laid
everything out and let the student reach
their own
conclusion yeah I am absolutely
surprised by this completely I never
expected this at all this came
out accidentally just we have
interactions like this on a daily basis
this one just happened to be captured on
camera and we were conducting a an a
broadcast at school I teach multimedia
and I teach students how to work with
camera and how to be on camera and the
student was getting cold feet to do the
newscast and so I said I'll show you
it's not difficult we'll do a little
warmup and here I'll just sit here ask
me whatever you want it's just a
conversation what's something
interesting that we could talk about you
know what's on your mind and that's the
question that came out and you saw the
rest unfold it was really fascinating to
watch the student and credit to the
student who was prepared to listen
listen to you I think because of the the
non-hostile environment you immediately
created uh was able to go on a kind of
Journey of exploration now I've been
crying out for uh schools and
universities to to follow this path
where students can actually debate these
things in a good environment hear other
sides to an argument and reach maybe a
better conclusion than the echo chambers
that fly around fueled by social media
and it was great at the end that he sort
of realized in the end there was nothing
really as off as he presumed from the
kind of toxic atmosphere around JK
rowy I think that's why the video
resonated was that you see in real time
a transformation a journey with a
beginning a middle and an end and he
does come to a realization and the
realization is larger than JK Rowling
this is about more than JK Rowling it's
the realization that he his prior
assumptions he was going off of well
I've heard that this is true true so
many people have told me that this is
true and when you experience that for
yourself and it crumbles then you have
to question logically what else am I
assuming to be true yes that perhaps
might not be and that changes the way
you view the world it completely it been
some great reaction uh to you a guy
called Vincent Lindero said let's build
an AI version of this teacher duplicate
him as many times needed and have
everyone learn and understand how to
think not what to think and a guy called
Lance said interesting I don't see him
dressing with multicolored garments or
weird hair no piercings or visible
tattoos looks in relatively decent shape
in control of the classroom and
discussion is this what the left calls
toxic masculinity because we need more
of it if it
is that's such a coincidence that you
brought up that quote that's the quote
that actually stuck out to me the most
because he said reasonably in shape and
I thought reasonably in shape in what re
in reason to what perhaps will provide
some uh critical thinking on that well
trust me compared to me you're look in
Olympian shape um what's your message to
to other Educators around the world who
maybe have been heading to a bad place
where they've been almost teaching Dogma
um fueled Again by maybe what x is
saying or what Instagram or Tik Tok is
saying what do you say to
them do not be afraid to allow these
conversations to occur because these
students have the ability to do what you
saw in that video and to reason their
way through these things and to learn
new ways to advance through life but
they will not be able to do so if not
given the opportunity sometimes it just
takes the right questions just a little
bit of prompting and leading by
example it's pivotal allow them to
happen don't live out of fear not
dissimilar actually to the art of
parenting I can tell you
I believe you I don't have kids at the
moment yeah I've got four of them and I
can tell you the same strategy actually
works if you just shout at kids and bark
at them and tell them what they should
be thinking and doing I think you end up
with you know kids who are quite damaged
if you allow them the freedom and the
space to reach their own decisions and
conclusions and thought processes
everybody wins um I'm talking of
everyone winning or not winning I see
that you agree with me that Barbie
shouldn't have been nominated for a best
pitcher Oscar that just once again shows
you have absolutely impeccable taste
Warren well I admire what they were able
to do is extremely creative being able
to do something like that with a movie
about a doll Barbie but the question is
what lens are we examining what is an
Oscar mean what's the lens that we're
looking at this through and I do think
that it comes down to the technical
artistic press that intangible elusive
thing that cannot be replicated with
given enough money given a large enough
budget you can go build a big Barbie
house on a back lot but something like
Braveheart Titanic there's certain it's
much difficult much more difficult to
replicate yeah completely um funny you
specialize in Hogwarts Harry Potter my
oldest son is absolutely addicted to
them he can recite all the movies from
the audio books blah blah blah blah blah
I've never watched any of it not thing
at all but we've got 40 seconds what is
the best life advice you can give me
from all your Harry Potter studies which
will enhance my
life voluntarily accept the unknown and
enter the unknown beneath the surface
perhaps it's the Chamber of Secrets
beneath the the surface of Hogwarts to
face the serpent and save jinny the
thing that will Ser that will turn you
to Stone when you see it out of fear
perhaps you've got to face it and you
can't be forced to do it you have to do
it voluntarily that's what's going to
make all the difference wow Warren
you've almost you've almost converted me
almost uh Warren Smith great to talk to
you keep up the great work we need more
teachers like you and it's a privilege
to have you on the show you can watch
Warren's full video on X and look it out
it's great that's it for me whatever
you're up to keep it uncensered and keep
it normal like Warren Smith and his
students good
night
hey very good morning to you thanks for
joining us you're with talk TV on TV on
radio online and we're on your smart
speaking what a happy start to Monday an
Arctic blast the royal family are up in
arms more problems with migration
welcome to Monday good morning Rosie
good morning Nick we're here in Tamworth
for you to find out exactly why some
people are traveling halfway around the
world and queuing for hours for one of
these The Humble British
potato a woman can become a man and a
man can become a woman and if you think
that you're certifiably
insane it's not in Labor's DNA to get
tough on immigration they don't feel it
they don't sense it no officer with your
level of training wakes up in the
morning and says what a great day to go
and shoot somebody this is done really
as a last result it's done in a response
emergency response
this concept that actually kids wouldn't
carry knives if they could go and play
Tiddly Winks at the you know the corner
of the street or whatever I think it's a
nonsense she was basically saying that
if I don't leave then she's going to
seize my equipment and everyone around
was just outraged there's a way to deal
with knif crime right I mean okay it
doesn't deal with the underlying
problems in society and all the rest
that actually stops people getting
killed a crossbow a hatchet most
crossbows multiple crossbow yeah
crossbows is what it says on the Press
crossbows and a carry on crossbows and a
hatchet and what a sword and a knife how
is that even technically possible sorry
yeah I've got a microchip in my left
hand let's see can we can you hold it to
the camera so we can see where is it I
can't see yeah you can't see it cuz it's
actually inside the web of my hand
here we
go it's carry on what just
happened was like brought to you by
steak C mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got a great mayor
sadique Khan brilliant
guy nobody is is spending any money
they're not prepared to do it I mean why
is that H quite simple the downturn in
the spend is three simple words
Financial fair
play stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red prouser popcorn I mean pop what what
is that Absolut